STEVEN BAZYL: Hi everyone,
I'm Steven Bazyl.
ALI AFSHAR: And I'm
Ali Afshar.
STEVEN BAZYL: And we're here
for another Google Drive
question time to talk about
what's new, and this is
actually our first one since a
very successful Google I/O.
ALI AFSHAR: So whoever came
to I/O, thank you
very much for coming.
If you've checked out our
videos online of the
presentations, thank
you for that.
If you haven't, please by all
means go and do that.
STEVEN BAZYL: There's a lot of
great sessions on everything
about what's new, to
working on Android,
lots of great content.
Today we're going to go through
some of the unanswered
questions on Stack Overflow and
maybe talk about some of
the newer features that we
launched about two weeks ago.
So I want to jump on to
the first one here.
ALI AFSHAR: Let's start.
The first question says, can one
add additional metadata to
Drive files, excluding the
description field?
STEVEN BAZYL: That's
a good question.
It's a good feature request.
It is unfortunately not
something that we have right
now, but it is definitely
something that we have talked
about internally, something I
personally would like to see
us add to the API.
But right now, the only things
you can do are the
description, or indexable text
is a way that you could attach
some data in a way that's
somewhat useful.
ALI AFSHAR: So can you
just mention--
you said using the
description.
I mean, this question
says excluding
the description field.
But how would someone use
that, for example?
STEVEN BAZYL: Description
is just arbitrary text.
It's not the file name.
It doesn't affect how it syncs,
but it does show up in
our previewer.
It is something that a client
could read out, so they can
put some structured data in
there, or at least some
meaningful data that
they can parse out.
It is user visible, though, so
you can't put in anything that
would come across as too
technical or gibberish.
ALI AFSHAR: Or some kind of data
format, like JSON, that
would be a struggle.
But indexable text,
on the other hand.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, indexable
text is an
interesting option for that.
So you can write text, and if
there's information that you
think would be useful for
search that might not be
easily extracted from
the actual file
itself, you can add that.
The problem though is I think in
this particular case, it's
probably not the right solution,
because you can't
read that information back.
You could do some very clever
hacks around searching and
testing for existence, but not
something I would actually
encourage anyone
to actually do.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so great.
So to summarize, unfortunately
not right now.
Something we're looking at
very, very strongly.
And there are some slight
workarounds, but just hold
that thought.
We'll get on that one.
STEVEN BAZYL: But I'd be very
happy when that's added.
A lot of really cool things
you can do once
you have that feature.
This looks like a Documents
List question.
And a fairly long one.
Commenter roles.
ALI AFSHAR: So the Documents
List API has been pretty much
replaced by the Drive
API, would you say?
STEVEN BAZYL: That is true.
As of Google I/O and Version
2 of the SDK and the API,
everything that was possible in
the Documents List API is
now possible, and I think
personally a lot easier to do,
in the Drive API.
ALI AFSHAR: So all of our
questions about the Documents
List API, our answer would
be, why don't you
use the Drive API?
STEVEN BAZYL: Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: So the question
is ACL role for commenter.
So this user would like to share
a document with some
users but only to allow them
to comment on a document.
Now, if you've used Google Docs,
you know there's the
commenting system in the
right-hand side.
You add a comment, and they get
emailed out, and they get
observed, and you can resolve
these comments.
Really powerful collaborative
feature.
So how would you do that
with the Drive API?
STEVEN BAZYL: I haven't actually
tried it, but in the
ACLs and the roles, there are is
additional roles, I think,
is where commenter is.
So you should be able to update
the metadata, adding in
the commenter role into the
additional role set, and in
theory, that should enable
that for that user.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's a
fine-grained kind of
permission tweak.
Our major permissions are either
you're the owner of a
file, you can write a file,
or you can read a file.
But the commenter additional
role allows readers to also be
able to comment.
So it gives just this slight
additional role.
So the answer to this would be
just to add the ACL, well, the
permission as we now
call it, with the
additional commenter role.
STEVEN BAZYL: And what's the
next one that we have?
ALI AFSHAR: The next question.
STEVEN BAZYL: Oh,
this is good.
It's already been answered.
That was a good one, though.
ALI AFSHAR: Well, let's
have a look at it.
Display images which are stored
in Google Drive on a
public website.
Is it possible to access display
files, like images,
which are stored in Google Drive
on a public website?
So, good question.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
So there are.
I mean you can certainly
make files public.
Displaying the actual image,
though, is a little bit more
complicated.
If you want to just put it in
an image tag, because of the
way the images are served.
Thumbnails, on the other hand,
could be displayed publicly,
but they are short-lived URLs,
mostly for security reasons.
But with a little bit of work,
you could make it work.
ALI AFSHAR: Say if you had an
image, and it was publicly
shared, how would you
go about embedding
that in your web app?
STEVEN BAZYL: That's
a good question.
That's a very good question.
The download URL for that, I
think even if it's public,
though, still requires
authentication.
Actually, the API does
now support cores.
You could load the image with
JavaScript and create the
image tags dynamically.
Just setting it as a source
attribute I don't think will
work with that.
ALI AFSHAR: And you could
do it on your back end.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's true.
You're right.
You could always proxy it
through a server, cache those
images on your own systems,
and so on.
ALI AFSHAR: So a bit of
programming using the API.
STEVEN BAZYL: Something
we could make easier.
ALI AFSHAR: And something we're
looking at making easier.
It would be really nice for
a public image if--
I mean, how would you feel
about that feature, if we
could just have a URI?
STEVEN BAZYL: I think
that would be
a very useful feature.
I mean, you could do the same
thing for HTML pages, for
anything that is a
public resource.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
Something I think we can
definitely do better.
STEVEN BAZYL: This one was
already answered, but there
are a couple more--
ALI AFSHAR: Unanswered
questions.
STEVEN BAZYL: Unanswered ones
that we probably should take a
look at first.
ALI AFSHAR: Oh, here's Steve's
favorite question.
Getting a list of files by
folder on Drive SDK.
I'm trying to build a web UI
for users to navigate the
Google Drive and select one
or more documents to be
referenced later on a website
from a database.
I'm currently building the
web interface in PHP.
The problem I'm facing, I can't
find a single function
to get a list of files
by folder ID.
So a list of all the files that
are children of a folder.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, and he
actually does point out in the
question, there is a child
collection that does let you
get all the items in a folder.
But as he points out,
it only returns back
the ID of the item.
So if you actually want to get
any information about that,
you then have to do a separate
request for each file to get
the metadata.
So I think as of yesterday,
there is actually a new search
parameter that you can use
in the files collection.
And you can query for folders
within a particular parent.
And I think the format is just
the expression, the ID of the
parent folder, and
then in parents.
And that will return back every
item in that parent
folder with all the metadata
included in a single request.
Something I actually ran into,
and something I was playing
with, and I'm very happy
that feature got added.
ALI AFSHAR: Our query format's
pretty cool, so you can
combine these things.
So if you just want folders
that are within a certain
folder, you ask for that.
So it's quite powerful, and this
is the latest feature as
of yesterday.
And we should bring
attention to this.
We're really keen about telling
you about our least
feature and what's changing
in the API.
So we do have a release notes
that we usually publish every
week or every other week
with the changes.
And that that's in our
documentation, so if you've
got any doubts or any interest
in what's changed recently, or
what the recent features have
been, please, by all means, go
and check that out.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, and
things are still
moving pretty quickly.
None of these are changes that
break anything, but as we get
more feedback from developers,
particularly because the API
is so new, we are adding
features at
a pretty good pace.
So definitely something
to keep a watch on.
What else do we have?
ALI AFSHAR: Let's have a look.
A Documents List API question.
How to get the field type
from AtomFeed returned
by Google list URL?
I guess that means the Google
Documents List API.
Whatever AtomFeed returned by
Google URL, I'm able to fetch
for column name but
not its type.
Is there any way to get the
data type of this column?
Do you know what that means?
I think it means the actual
type that the chunk of XML
would map to.
How did you do that?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, it's
a good question.
That would probably just
be in the schema for
that particular API.
ALI AFSHAR: It's kind of more
interesting with the Drive
API, because you would have
the same problem if
you just parse it.
Of course it's JSON rather than
XML by default, but each
of these resources has a kind
field that's called.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, each of the
JSON objects has a kind,
which basically is
the object type.
Basically with JSON, it's
roughly, loosely typed.
Integers are integers, but
some of the string types,
there's a lot of nuances
in-- is it a URL?
Is it just arbitrary text?
But the Atom stuff, all that
information about typing would
be in the schema itself for
that particular API.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, as much
as we really want
to say on that one.
Some of the client libraries use
this type of information,
some of them don't.
Let me think of one that does.
So that the object of C library
actually registers a
programming type for each of
the JSON types, and then it
does it like that.
But the Python one totally
ignores it, for example.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's true.
Actually, I think the Ruby one
is a little bit more flexible.
It will do either format,
strings or integers, or
whatever type you
want to give it.
But that's one of the cool
things with the new API is the
discovery information.
The old Atom one was based on
XML schema, the new API, the
Drive API in particular, it does
have a schema document,
but it's in JSON.
And you can actually look at
those for the API and get very
detailed information about the
structure of each item in
there, what the types
are, and so on.
And some of our client libraries
will actually use
that to give nice, strongly
typed representations for all
the objects.
ALI AFSHAR: We're not just
trying to be inconsistent with
the client libraries.
I think they're built to suit
the language specifically.
So Java would be crazy without
this static typing.
STEVEN BAZYL: Java, .NET,
Objective C, those are all a
little bit more strongly
typed.
ALI AFSHAR: Go.
STEVEN BAZYL: Gp.
ALI AFSHAR: But to do that
in the JavaScript
library would be insane.
STEVEN BAZYL: You're not going
to have that in JavaScript or
Python, or even Ruby,
or some of the
other dynamic languages.
ALI AFSHAR: So you may notice
we have client libraries for
all these languages.
Please go ahead and use them.
All right, a question about
resumable upload.
While resuming upload, getting
the size of data that had been
uploaded always fails with a
500 Internal Server error.
I was looking at this today.
I think it's a bug, actually,
so we should look at that.
But the cool thing about
resumable upload is that if
your upload fails during
uploading a file, at any point
you can then later query the
server and ask, how much have
I uploaded?
And we will return an answer.
And this is a question of, how
do we perform that query?
The client libraries
have it built in.
He's actually using the Java
library, which is doing the
right thing.
And I tried it today, and I
can't reproduce this error.
So it's either a bug or
something we're not doing
quite right.
STEVEN BAZYL: And it is a 500
error, which does indicate
there was something probably
wrong with that particular
request or that file, but
something to look at.
ALI AFSHAR: So in general, if
you get 500 errors doing stuff
like this, the recommendation
is to retry.
STEVEN BAZYL: Could be just
a transient error.
And usually, if it is something
wrong with the
request itself, you'll get back
an error message in the
body itself that it is actually
pretty indicative of
what the issue is.
ALI AFSHAR: So it
should be a 400.
STEVEN BAZYL: It should
be, yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: And we're trying to
get better at giving useful
error messages.
We just had some changes last
week to try and just trying to
explain what you're doing
wrong in the request.
And we do appreciate this is
something we haven't been
entirely great at, so we're
trying to improve.
One word, if you do get a 400
error with no information on
why, please get in touch with
us, because that's the kind of
error that we want to tag some
useful information so you know
what you're doing wrong.
Of course, 500s should never
really happen, should they?
STEVEN BAZYL: No.
On the resumable uploads,
you mentioned if
it does fail, retry.
But there is a set period
of time, though, right?
You can't just keep
retrying forever.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
STEVEN BAZYL: Do you happen to
know how long those uploads
are resumable for?
ALI AFSHAR: I don't
know exactly.
I believe it's in the order
of hours, where that
session will remain.
But I certainly wouldn't
try the next day.
STEVEN BAZYL: That, most
likely, will fail.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
But they stick around
for a bit.
And that's so that you
can upload huge
files, up to 10 gigabytes.
STEVEN BAZYL: There was
another interesting
conversation on the resumable
stuff, that I'm not entirely
sure if each of the client
libraries does this the way
that it's really meant
to be used.
Some people tend to
use resumable for
chunking their uploads.
But it turns out that's
actually not the
way that we'd recommend.
We'd actually recommend trying
to upload the entire file in
one shot, and then only resuming
in the case it fails.
But I do there's a couple of
the libraries that don't
actually do that by default.
ALI AFSHAR: That's right.
And chunking is really useful in
situations where you have a
limited amount of time, or you
have to defer the upload to a
task queue, or this kind of
thing, web server platforms,
that kind of thing.
But actually, we don't
recommend it's done.
I think Python is one
library which
uses chunking by default.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
And I know the Ruby one
as well does that.
Something on my to
do list to fix.
ALI AFSHAR: So Steve is the
maintainer for the Ruby
library, so if you have
any problems with it.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's right.
You can come and just
yell at me.
That's all right.
Let's see.
Can't retrieve--
ALI AFSHAR: Can't retrieve
file metadata from Google
Drive, comma, 404.
I'm having some seriously
weird issues with the
Google Drive API.
We're sorry about that
to start with.
Bear with me here.
There's a lot to explain.
Oh, goodness.
STEVEN BAZYL: All right.
So he has an account.
ALI AFSHAR: He has an account.
He got the API working.
All right.
STEVEN BAZYL: I think I know
what the issue is.
ALI AFSHAR: I know what the
issue is already as well,
actually, and I think
I've actually
commented on this one.
So using the picker?
Well go on then, if you
know what it is.
STEVEN BAZYL: Well I didn't read
the whole thing, but I'm
guessing he's using
the file scope.
I saw a comment in there about
changing his app ID.
ALI AFSHAR: So he was using the
file scope, and when he
changed it to the full scope,
it started to work.
But actually, he's
using the picker.
So before we go into this one--
and this might take the
full of our time remaining--
but can you explain the
difference between the file
scope and the full scope?
STEVEN BAZYL: Sure.
So the file scope is something
that we added when we first
launched the Drive API
a few months ago.
And it's something that we
actually encourage people to
use if it's their use cases,
and actually try to make it
for their use cases
as best they can.
But the idea is simple.
Rather than have all your
applications request access to
everything that a user has in
their Drive account, which
could be a lot of things which
aren't relevant to that
application.
It could be a lot of files that
are potentially sensitive.
It could be financial
records or so on.
The file scope allows the user
to give access only to those
files that they choose to share
with that application or
that that application
created by itself.
So it's much more restrictive,
much more secure for users,
because they know that that
application only has access to
a very limited set
of information.
For that to work, however, there
are some things that
have to happen.
So for us to be able to mark a
file as being openable by an
app, we need some action to
tell us, and that's either
when the user clicks on a file
in the Drive UI, and they say,
open this file in an app, or
if it's something that was
created in the API, or in this
other, what we call a picker,
which is an embeddable
Drive UI.
It's a JavaScript component.
Any of those things give us an
indication that that user
decided it's OK for this
app to read that file.
So that's the scope.
The other is, of course, the
full Drive scope, which gives
you access to anything, whether
or not the user
explicitly made that
action or not.
ALI AFSHAR: And so in this case,
the developer is using
the picker, but then once he's
used the picker to select a
file, he's not actually
getting access
with the file scope.
So that thing that you've just
described is not happening.
Now this is usually because
of one of two reasons.
And the first one is that
there's a bug, which I don't
think it is in this case.
The second reason is the
picker is a JavaScript
component that runs inside your
browser, so that's really
subject to what cookies you've
got, if you're multiply logged
in with multiple users.
And that's what I think
has happened here.
This file that he's testing
with is actually shared
between both users.
And I think the JavaScript
component is being loaded with
the wrong user or using the
wrong cookies, so he's
actually giving access
so the wrong user.
Now, there is a way
around that.
STEVEN BAZYL: There is an option
to explicitly share the
picker for a user, and they
can just set user.
ALI AFSHAR: Set auth
user, maybe?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah,
that's right.
Set auth user, which you
just give it, is
it the email address?
ALI AFSHAR: I think you can give
it the email address or
the user ID, as we call it,
and soon we'll be able to
parse in an OAuth
token as well.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's a
good feature then.
There's a couple other
things that could go
wrong with the picker.
So in addition to multi-logon
issues, where you're logged in
with two accounts and you might
be showing the wrong
one, also, you do need to set
your app ID in the JavaScript
when you build a picker.
So if you're not setting the
correct app ID or omitted it,
then we don't know which
app we should actually
set that bit for.
So there's a couple things
you have to get right.
Make sure it's the right user,
make sure it's the right app,
and I don't think there's
any origin issues,
but there may be.
I know that we actually
have a--
a a component to this, we have
a sharing dialogue, which
actually just launched
about two weeks ago.
And I know that one, actually,
is very sensitive to
JavaScript origins, making sure
that the URL of the page
that's showing that dialogue
matches either the open or the
create URLS for the app.
Picker may be sensitive
to that as well.
ALI AFSHAR: Right, I
didn't know that.
See, the picker, of course, we
can use with other things it's
not just Drive you can
use with images and--
STEVEN BAZYL: Actually, it's a
really cool little component.
You can do image search, maps,
even, a whole bunch of things
that it supports.
ALI AFSHAR: With a good
customizable UI, you can show
a list or thumbnails,
and you can turn off
the menu on the side.
It's a good, well-styled
component that I think just
shows that your application
is using Google
Drive in a good way.
So we like it.
Please use it.
Should we end there?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, seems
like a good--
ALI AFSHAR: Good place to end?
STEVEN BAZYL: Good
stopping point.
Of course we'll go back and
actually answer all of these
on Stack Overflow.
ALI AFSHAR: Unless someone wants
lots of points, in which
case you would have
taken notes and go
and answer them now.
STEVEN BAZYL: That's right.
You can jump in right now before
we go and get yourself
some Stack Overflow cred.
ALI AFSHAR: So please, please,
if you do have questions,
please ask them on
Stack Overflow.
We do take a lot of time
and attention to this,
so please do that.
That's the best way of getting
things solved.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
And we'll be back for another
one of these, is it later this
week, or next week?
ALI AFSHAR: Next week.
STEVEN BAZYL: Next week.
So we'll hopefully
see everyone.
Well, we won't see you, but
hopefully you'll see us.
And maybe one of these, we'll
have an interactive Hangout,
invite some people in, some
other developers, and people
to talk about what they've
been doing with Drive.
ALI AFSHAR: That
would be great.
STEVEN BAZYL: All right.
Thank you very much.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank
you very much.
Take care.